welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode 3
lamentis in which loki and sylvie play a
game of who
is enchanting whom folks there's so much
to break down from huge reveals about
the tva to asgardian and other alien
languages to translate
maybe even huge portions of this episode
that might be one of our variants
trapping the other in an illusion
so let's loose the juice from our tin
pad and drop in
the episode opens in an illusion that
the loki variant
sylvie placed tva hunter c20 under
during the events of episode 2. so
opening this episode in an illusion
instructs us as viewers to watch this
episode very carefully
because notice how over the marvel
studios title leading into this we hear
this music there's something in the
water
this is called demons by haley kyoko
which is fitting for the way sylvia and
loki are called devils this episode
you're no travelers you're devils and
the way sylvie has been compared to a
demon in stained glass
and the lyrics of this song refer to
having demons in one's head and say
there's something in the water
all reflecting how sylvie is nc20s head
using a reconstructed memory of fruity
drinks to
intoxicate c20 into revealing tva
secrets
later this episode sylvie reveals that
this particular memory from c20 was from
hundreds of years prior from c20s past
as a human
on earth before she became a variant
confirming the theory that i
shared in last week's miss minutes video
that all tva employees are variants with
memories wiped and forced into servitude
by the time keepers which poses
all kinds of implications like perhaps
mobius was a jet ski salesman in his
past life
maybe from san diego judging from that
snow globe in
rensselaer's office that mobius didn't
remember getting that could have been
his precious relic that was kept in
evidence also maybe rensslayer could
have been a teacher or a principal at
frankly roosevelt high school that that
pen was from but this also explains why
c20 was so panicked repeating it was
real it was real
after coming out of her enchantment
showing that her visions of her past
life weren't just fantastical dreams but
subconscious memories of
real events remember b15 also looks
shaken
i suspect she too could have been linked
with her past life now the opening shot
of the episode is this tropical themed
mug of a head half drain reflecting the
way c20s mind is being drained by sylvie
in this moment they discuss
brain freezes but only c20 gets one
maybe silvia doesn't get one because
loki variants are technically frost
giants they're not affected by cold but
check out that patron in the background
on the right looks a bit like pietro
maximoff i mean i only mentioned it
because silvi's enchantment works
similar to wanda's hex reality
which also featured an alternate reality
pietro in it there's actually a lot of
parallels like later when sylvie screams
in frustration her green sorcery blasts
out like a shockwave
similar to how wanda's agonized scream
created a shockwave just could be a sign
that variant loki's could be potential
nexus beings with capabilities of
setting the terms of a single reality
similar to how wanda can do that
and if you think about it wanted to
create the westview hex
out of grief over vision's absence and
what does loki say to sophie here
you lack vision black vision but the
illusions also work the same way because
notice that moment c20 suspects
something is off about the reality
sylvie switches it
jumping ahead suddenly to night time
similar to how whenever a glitch in the
matrix happened in west view wanda would
suddenly edit past it and progress
forward in time in that case a sitcom
decade forward also sylvie grabs
c20's wrist to get her to refocus on her
after the switch showing how physical
contact is needed to form that neural
link for the enchantment now the music
has changed to deep blue by ladytron
with lyrics foreshadowing the whole
journey ahead for sylvia on lumantus1
seeking a power station on a train out
of town
hey by the way included in our loki
inspired merch is our latest augmented
reality shirt which when viewed through
an ar
app the god of mischief comes alive
folks who've already gotten it have sent
us some awesome videos
really grabbing merch like this is the
best way you can support new rockstars
so head on over to newrockstarsmerch.com
and when you get that loki out of time
shirt you get an option to write in a
custom shout out in our inside marvel
after show
sylvie infiltrates the tva passing this
poster that reads the timeline is only
as strong as
its weakest moment with his agent all
tangled up in the timeline
ironic considering this is exactly what
sylvia has just done to the dba
but notice that tva cops scream soviet
erases him
his whale is digitally filtered actually
similar to the sound of neo scream that
moment he got him plugged in matrix
[Music]
and that may be what sylvia is doing
here unplugging these mine slaves and
restoring them to their natural states
which might be why it seems to bring her
so much satisfaction to do it loki
snatches silvie's tin pad and depletes
its juice
leaving them marooned on lamentis 1 in
the year 2077
as another planet is about to collide
with it melancholia style
actually kind of like the way thanos
grabbed a moon and threw it at titan but
lumens is actually in the comics it's an
outworld planet on the edge of cree
space it's from the annihilation
prologue issue which features the
destruction of
xandar now 2077 would be about six
decades
after xandar's off-screen destruction by
thanos prior to infinity war
so perhaps we're now seeing the
aftermath of the nova corps inability to
protect xandar's colonies here lementus
is a mining colony i think based on
lv426 and aliens which we know was a
reference for this episode based on the
guards being named private hudson and
corporal hicks which are bill paxton and
michael bean's characters and aliens
sylvia tries to enchant loki but her
magic flickers out on his head though
the way it did with the tba
what are you doing what are you doing
yeah sylvie's reaction makes me think
loki in this moment might have tried to
rebound the spell and enchant her
from this moment on it's not really
clear if either have been enchanted but
it is weird that the meteor shower
outside subsides after this despite this
oncoming planet coming closer
on the walk they bicker don't call me
variant i'm sorry but i'm not calling
some
faded photocopy of me loki good cause
that's not who i am anymore
i'm silvie now oh you changed your name
brilliant it's called an alias this
confirms that sylvie did begin a loki
variant but due to loki's sex fluidity
just takes a female form but the name
sylvie was an alias that she chose so
despite using the term enchant a lot
she's not
exactly sylvie lushen enchantress from
the comics but really a new character
inspired by both lady loki and
enchantress and they enter this town
that is covered with alien lettering
which from what i can tell matches
neither the scroll language written on
rocket scanner and guardians of the
galaxy nor the established mcu cree
alphabet
making me wonder if this could be
zandarian but we don't really have a way
to translate but
that won't stop me folks so look at the
structure that sylvie walks up to trying
to trick loki and handing over the temp
pad to charge it that top word has six
characters and using the substitution
decoding process i use for the riddler
cipher and the batman trailer you always
start by looking for repeating symbols
and some do repeat the second and the
fourth are the same letter and the third
and the fifth are another letter
so we're looking at a sequence of one
two three two three four so then you
gotta do some guesswork based on really
whatever the most commonly used letters
tend to be
in combinations with each other i'm
wondering if those could be r-e-r-e
and the word could be pre-wreck for
pre-requirements
and all those names in red on the side
being the names of colonists given
priority status for evacuation which is
why this building would be the one
building left in town with the lights on
this this is
what i do with my time so sylvie kicks
open the door to the trailer only to be
blasted with
a gun
which looks a lot like a recreation of
that moment that bride tried to get the
drop on bud and kill bill volume 2.
inside loki notices the woman's framed
photo with her husband
kind of looks like a nod to grant wood's
american gothic but common misconception
that does not depict a married couple
but a farmer and his daughter
kind of similar to how loki and hela are
step siblings in the mcu but in norse
mythology hella is loki's daughter
so at the train station is a line of
angry colonists trying to evacuate
including some kids and you know that
means camera lends eye contact
[Music]
but further back in the line there are
these two guys that appear to be twins
which could be another interesting
matrix parallel because in that woman
the red dress scene the wachowskis
populated the extras that bumped into
neo
with twins twins really as a way to
evoke this dreamlike simulation this
could be another possible clue that this
maybe loki or sylvie having enchanted
the other
in an illusion but real quick i want to
do a loki and change my shirt
but before continuing thanks to display
for sponsoring this video
display makes high quality art prints on
metal they have
over a million great artist designs
including many from the worlds of gaming
anime and comics they have a new
collection of licensed loki posters
including versions of the tva posters
we've seen in the background in the
first few episodes
check out some of my favorite displays
using the link in the description you'll
also get a sweet discount
buy one or two disc plates and get 27
off that goes up to 37
if you buy three or more disc plates
they mount on your wall with a magnet
no tools needed and no holes in the wall
with display you can build collections
of the things you're passionate about
right on your wall with every disk plate
that you buy you plant one tree through
displaced partnership with the
non-profit trees for the future
check out some of my favorite marvel
star wars and film inspired displays and
get your
own using the link in the description
and you'll get a special discount
up to 37 off when you buy three or more
you'll be supporting our channel and
making some major upgrades to your walls
so click on the link and get your own
displate
now the wealthy getting elite access to
this train is a bit similar to bong joon
ho's snow piercer
in which he uses a train as kind of a
marxist allegory
in which the rich get luxury cars to the
front but that capitalist engine
ultimately serves
no one similar to how this train leads
to no one's escape from destruction
now loki has to sit in the backwards
facing seat on the train
trains also feature prominently in the
movie inception where in the opening
sequence
nash and arthur sit in a train car
backwards facing the mark
cyto who was actually trapped in their
false reality i mean i just find it
interesting that they called attention
to the seating like this
and after some indeterminate amount of
time sylvie wakes up
confused now facing the opposite
direction in the frame
and this was after loki had asked her
earlier how long do we have
12 hours or so and now sylvie refers to
her memory as
just blips of a dream at this point now
sylvie learned earlier than loki did in
her timeline that she was adopted and
had to teach herself magic making me
think that her mother figure from her
timeline might not have been frigga
on one event report that loki read in
episode 2 the name
sylvie lauffy daughter appeared the
surname being instead of lauthy's son
son of laufey
daughter of laufey so i wonder if
perhaps sylvie's maternal figure could
have been
hella who in her timeline might have
accompanied odin in that battle against
the frost giants in which lauffy's
offspring was taken as a ward
and that hela could have left an
impression on sylvie maybe even given
her that sword before hella was banished
by odin sylvie also reveals having a
lover
managed to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a
postman
whilst running across time from one
apocalypse to another she could be
referring to stan lee who did appear as
a fedex delivery driver in civil war and
then bragged about that to the watchers
in guardians vol 2.
by the way he also cameoed in the 2005
fantastic four film as a mailman
some are also saying it could be that
delivery driver in west view but postman
reminds me of the song nick fury used to
inspire the name captain marvel
marvel sounds a lot better you know like
the marvel apps
wait oh yes wait a minute mr postman
fury would be an interesting pairing for
sylvie but why not the person who end up
taking that name
carol danvers because loki reveals
himself as bisexual
a bit of both i suspect the same as you
and sophie doesn't really argue with
that and carol would have been a
super-powered galaxy hopper whose
whereabouts were unknown from 1995 to
so silly wakes up to find loki's singing
now according to the captions this is an
asgardian making this the first time
we've heard
asgardian as a language in the mcu
though it's really norwegian
his lyrics translate to in stormy black
mountains i wander alone
over the iceberg i pull myself forth in
the apple garden stands the maiden fair
and i sing when will you come home loki
drunk calls back thor's move in the
first thor film
another and he tells sylvia that he's
not drunk just
full which is another in joke because a
norwegian to be full means to be drunk
loki gives an answer for their chat
about what love is love
is a dagger but ultimately when you
reach for it
it isn't real they're calling the famous
soliloquy in shakespeare's macbeth when
macbeth hallucinates an imaginary dagger
perhaps here
the dagger is a symbol of loki's
betrayal of sylvie with everything
they're going through
being a kind of dagger of loki's
enchantment now during the brawl notice
how silvia uses her crown as a weapon
this is a move that loki did in thor
ragnarok and as silvi pulls her sword
out of the bar you can barely make out
some writing on it they look like viking
runes similar to the ones that are
carved into mjolnir and stormbreaker
in this case they're kind of hard to
translate but to me it looks like
t th
and then h s u and then maybe
s u p n i don't know there's like a
dozen different norse rune alphabets out
there and i haven't been able to line up
any of these perfectly i like how when
loki hits the ground
outside the train he makes the same
plank pose that he did when hitting the
sanctum floor after falling for 30
minutes in ragnarok and then he reveals
the temp pad but it is broken
though again perhaps what we are looking
at here is just part of an illusion by
loki to manipulate sylvie
into revealing exactly how her
enchantment works
because only now does sylvie finally
reveal that she mind controls by
reconstructing memories
and she also reveals to loki that the
tba are actually memory-wiped variants
which are big things that loki has
gained through this experience which
then leads to this seemingly
impossible long take through the
collapsing city of sheru now at first
glance this awesome looking sequence
appears to be
a three minute unbroken long take but
like many long takes a movie and film it
is actually
several shots stitched together with
hidden cuts if you look closely
shot one loki and sylvia entered through
the tunnel loki steps on a barrier to
see the gates closing and then the
camera pants as
two runners pass the frame cut on the
pan there
and shot two following the two of them
down the alley camera orbits them a few
times and then crane up on a vfx shot of
that colliding planet cracking in half
and then a meteor striking a nearby
building
flashing the frame cut there now onto
shot three of them as they duck from
debris and run towards an explosion that
blows
them back tilting the camera and filling
the frame with smoke cut there
to shock four where the camera tilts
back up with loki's rise
and then they run into that cafe and
they confront some guards i think there
were some cuts hidden in there on the
stunts but
definitely a cut when the camera passes
a beam onto shot five
as they run and have their way cut off
and they take cover they follow another
running woman back to that same building
that collapses crane up on a vfx shot of
that collapse
cut there to shot six where they run and
loki freezes that tower from crushing
them reverses it back
up and then right after as loki runs
right with the whip pan there's a really
hard to spot cut there
notice loki's body from two different
shots are layered on top of each other
barely overlapping leading to shot seven
where loki and sylvie fight off the last
of the guards at the gate only to see
the ark get destroyed by meteors
as loki's charm foreshadowed we got some
fireworks now notice that in their last
moves loki and sylvie do these same leg
sweeps on the guards mirror images of
each other some are saying that loki
might have used a stolen time stone to
stop and reverse that tower collapse but
after loki used telekinesis to summon
that roomba i later realized that we've
also seen loki use telekinesis to throw
over all the furniture in that prison
cell in the dark world so this is
something that he can do
also that time stone only would have
worked if lamentus won in 2077
is that exact prune timeline that that
time stone was taken from and since
silvia created the whole bunch of
branches with her bombing i just think
it would be really hard for loki to
think ahead so perfectly also i'm pretty
sure we heard that time stone clunk back
in the drawer
really if loki had a functional time
stone here he would have used it in
dozens of ways
but i still believe it is possible that
for all of these events on lamentist one
or at least part of sylvie after waking
up the train at some point
could be part of loki's enchantment on
her
designed to gain sylvie's trust to learn
what he needed about the tva
so that he can turn her in and get back
in their good graces
whether or not that's the case not being
quite sure if we're under loki's
enchantment at any given moment is what
makes the show so enchanting and the
credit sequence has been updated with
photos of loki and sylvie together
evoking how loki called her a poor
photocopy of him
here both are black and white
photocopies all while bonnie guitar's
dark
moon plays with the lyrics paralleling
the way loki in silly's scheme
was cut off by a dark moon or
it was a planet it looked like a moon
but they called it the planet anyway
support this channel by checking out our
new loki inspired merch options
especially that loki out of time shirt
at new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you